parce qu'il va y avoir une question de
chacun pour yassine
on va commencer par vous et eric
naulleau mais avant de poser ma question
je pourrais corriger une exactitude vous
n'êtes pas un collègue de ris ce risque
d'un caricaturiste vous êtes un comique
officiel vous avez un pied dans le
pouvoir un pied dans la caricature un
pied à l'elysée un pied sur canal + dans
la pluie en fin
vous l'avez eu longtemps he is no
résidence position quand une bonne fois
pour toutes vous vous êtes un humoriste
de régime
bon je viens tu dans les pays de l'est
s'il a existé dans les pays de l'est je
suis athée et les terroristes yacine
avant d'avoir eu cette finition alors
j'ai justement maintenant le reste chez
moi sous macron d'abord existait pas non
mais alors déjà je pourrais vous
répondre
la dgd servir je ne suis pas allé vous
avez une mission auprès de la ville
pourquoi est-ce que je peux je vois là
genève employés si nous dit voilà je dis
juste que ce ce que je sais c'est que
yassine est proche des banlieues et je
pense que voilà c'est pour ça voilà vous
qui vous a demandé où vous a demandé
voilà de d'essayer de voir voilà deux
des néo d'aidé au niveau de la ville
pour voir ce que ce qu'on pouvait faire
c'est ça je vais vous répondre juste
impressionnant répondre eric naulleau
alors déjà il s'avère que le respect
voudrais de ne pas blâmer la carrière de
quelqu'un parce que vous même vous avez
participé peut-être à la montée de ma
petite carrière puisque je vous ai reçus
dans de nombreuses émissions avant même
que macro commence à faire de la
politique
une ce nombre assez suffisant pour que
vous n'êtes indien dans n'importe quoi
est fait de zine et juste avec de l'eau
je vais au bout comme ça je vous réponds
pas beaucoup de mensonges alors essayé
de dire un truc vraie âme et de temps en
temps ces jeunes juges fini ma phrase je
sais que vous êtes plus habitué à voir
des gens de mon espèce vous livrer des
plats des livres ou que de vous répondre
je vais vous répondre je ne suis pas
client chez les libéraux d'accord très
bien j'ai eu peur non plus alors avec
katia merci non juste vous dire quelque
chose inexactitudes allez juste quelque
chose avec naulleau je sais que vous
êtes excité juste je vous dis quelque
chose vous verrez la différence si je
m'excite mais c'est un jeu fait c'est
vrai c'est vos rubriques les bons noms
mais il ya sida les i je voudrais que
vous fassiez une phrase sans
inexactitudes sans caricature mais là je
vous répondrai que c'est donc tout à
l'heure j'ai c'est de démarrer vous n'y
arrivez pas les normes de ce que vous
racontez nous la collection événement
avec jimmy vous arrive pas avec moi si
si je m'engage à bien et jimmy à froid
comme entre tout ça je vais à luz
je sens qu'elle admirablement avec je
vais devenir avec vous mais moins bien
barré allez allez allez au colloque
c'est quand vous avez un peu d'antenne
vous êtes toute l'antenne jonah lomu
juste vous préciser quelque chose un
moment je suis pas un humoriste
d'origine je suis déjà un humoriste au
régime
et deuxièmement je vais vous dire
quelque chose je voudrais dire et
comment dire m'éliminer du débat à 10
ans comme si j'étais le bouffon du roi
que je met un chapeau le soir et que je
vais voir macro délasser irrespectueux
et c'est pas comme ça que j'ai dit ça
dans matière humoristes de régie du
régime région c'est c'est un peu c'est
le bras armé voilà de bakoudou bacon
dans l'humour presque fixée voila voila
four et au moulin mais c'est que
maintenant je n'aime pas me recevoir du
conseil et ville alors je finis ensuite
je vous dis juste quelque chose je pense
que je vous ai jamais vu dans l'une des
salles dans l'année mais spectacle bien
je sais que vous êtes humoriste d'accord
donc alors n attendez à partir du moment
où vous n'êtes pas venu mais pas savoir
ce que je fais ce qui manque aux russes
avaient un train qui se développe
beaucoup moi j'y crois beaucoup c'est
internet
soyez attentifs vous allez voir
incroyable et je vous ai vu sur internet
si je vous ai pas vu dans une salle à je
vous jure l'émotion voudrait que si vous
venez dans une salle c'est pas comme
quand on regarde un extrait d'internet
je sais que si moi je me fiais seulement
extrait de d'internet vous concernant je
me dirai ce mec est vraiment bête donc
fait attention mais redonne chemin ils
n'ont rien a mieux lancé l'an 12 est sur
scène mais je comprends pas vous expirez
en dehors de ses lecteurs ne va pas
avoir une opinion sur votre express
musique n'y a pas de soucis vous êtes là
en train de dire il est pas collègues je
vous dis je suis trois fois par semaine
en spectacle à paris au théâtre de dix
heures et il était un des ventes avant
divers
je suis un problème que les
caricaturistes qui est donné de tester
les limites de la liberté d'expression
qui est de blesser des gens et suscité
des réactions et les dans la même
commune
la raison
parce que sa voiture alors qu'elle
entamait tendue en entier l'a déjà ces
choses je trouve que tu l'as tu pour le
coup tu peux avoir des accords avec lui
mais lui lui reprochez pas lui enlever
les sens de son métier de faire rire et
compris en provoquant des gens tu peux
pas vous l'avez écouté la radio est
aussi non bah écoutez le il n'est pas
plus que je vous ai dit alors éric votre
question non j'ai corrigé une dernière
chose que je peux pas le laisser passer
votre votre petite pique la sueur des
libéraux j'habite au métro couronnes
vous avez déjà atteints de démence et
parra c'est comme me dire j'adore noir
non métro couronnes oui mais vous voyez
un peu l'environnement du métro
couronnes en billets valentin on n'est
pas des civils pourrait téléspectateurs
laisse le parisien centre belleville
minimes la couronne s'est il ya une très
fameuse mosquée jamais à 50 mètres de
cette mosquée dont il m'arrive donc vous
a dit m'arrive de croiser quelques
grammes et même quelques musulmans
donc ne dit pas rien comme moi vous ne
les voyez comment ils vont vous livrer
une pizza parce que ce que vous dites
effectivement vous ne voulez vraiment
très très con mais on avait commencé par
boire donc moi pour mon bien cher le
peuple japonais je mange des nudges
maintenant à venir non c'est vous qui
les jeux japonais
il avait bien voilà c'est vous qui avez
vous ce savoureux vous avez dit en fait
vous ne voyez des arabes quand il voue
énormément désignant des gens comme moi
il s'avère que je vois tout le monde
avait l'air mois déjà je vois à travers
vous juste le la la il on craque on sait
pas n'importe quoi je veux je n'ai plus
tôt prendre à la maison vous allez très
surpris car et en os logement dire
regardez pas ce qui peut poser la
question je vous donne une réponse comme
talent vous avez dit franchement moi
j'ai mes mots parce que moi dans son
racisme il est de qualité
vous êtes leader price vous n'êtes même
pas bon et vous avez su mais même pas
l'idée que de direction s'établir à
métro couronnes dessus non mais attendez
vous avez quoi de l'offre qui se battent
en duel à côté d'un foyer mal hier ça y
est vous connaissez les maliens ont
vraiment marre à l'aller c'est pas bien
mais arrêtez de condescendants 10 ans
j'habite à couronne
non mais c'est tout ne parlez pas de
délit verront des trucs comme ça c'est
pas de votre niveau même vous vous êtes
au dessus de ça c'est dire là il s'avère
que moi ma femme ne fait pas manger je
commence souvent des livres ou ai je pas
de problème avec alors qu'eric je
voudrais demander à monsieur bennett un
mort et il a pas l'air très en forme ce
soir les meilleurs sur scène
s'il est prêt à s'excuser et s'il est
prêt à retirer un tweet ignoble ouais il
a posté à l'intention de zineb el
rhazoui
une saisine et charlie hebdo qu'il a
quitté depuis 2010 est et qui provoque
assez régulièrement des polémiques dont
nous nous sommes fait l'écho sur
d'autres plateaux notamment à touche pas
à mon poste exactement puisqu'elle avait
elle s'est mise elle avait notamment
clamé d'ailleurs mais ici on en avait
parlé il faut tirer à balles réelles
dans les banlieues donc ça et provoqué
un énorme tollé
et c'est vrai que elle aussi on le dit
elle a une certaine immunité auprès des
bien pensants je le dis voilà il faut
dire la vérité on peut par escrocs la
pratique et puisque voilà c'est une
rescapée de charlie hebdo ont dit la
vérité donc presque intérêts n'étaient
pas là c'est vrai voilà c'est une
enseigne de charlie hebdo et voilà donc
elle est extrêmement elles apprennent
extrêmement beaucoup de sécurité autour
d'elle elle est extrêmement menacée mais
c'est vrai qu'elle jouit d'une certaine
immunité et on le comprend on peut le
comprendre voilà auprès de la presse
bien pensante dès qu'on s'attaque un peu
asie des balles raddaoui on le paiera
très cher on a on le paye très cher et
tout le monde vous tombe dessus très
bien si elle reste voilà exactement oui
c'est vrai que mathieu béda scolaire
j'avais dit moi aussi que c'était
inadmissible qu elle y dit il faut tirer
à balles réelles en second lieu moi
aussi je ferai une amie soit là c'est
inadmissible c'est d'aller jeunes
allaient provoquer c'est ni bon pour la
police parce que voilà ces libyens pour
la police ni bien pour les banlieues
d'accord avec vous donc voilà si on
revenait de temps là-dessus
après il avait donc je dirai simplement
savoir si vous êtes prêts alors on va
reprendre la nouvelle année gillet ben
el rhazoui el rhazoui avait dit que là
dès 2020 soit celle de la victoire sur
le fascisme islamique et que la france
soit le pays où il sera terrasse et
bonne année
happy new year donc on voit qu'elle est
bilingue et yassine belattar elle a
elle-même simulateur a répondu
inch'allah tu es plus là en 2020 alors
ma question est la suivante est ce que
vous trouvez pertinents intelligente
responsable d'associer la religion
musulmane à travers l'expression inch
allah est une menace de mort étant donné
les amalgames il a fait toute la journée
entre justement l'islam et le terrorisme
est ce que vous trouvez que c'est le
truc le plus intelligent que vous ayez
fait parce que vous êtes prêt à vous en
excusé et a retiré ce tweet le lui
persiste à qualifier de laisser mon père
c'est mon père
voilà il faut sorte la poubelle non
peut-être aussi lorsque je fais c'est
que ce tweet est avant tout et je vous
l'envoie